thank you very much for that
introduction that I'm sorry I didn't
bring a cello to to calm you all down I
don't have a very clear understanding of
what it is that you would like to hear
me talk about other than that I was told
that you have an interest in development
but that interest in development might
lead you to ask questions and so my
thought was to give you a short
introduction and then even over to you
guys to such questions as you think
might be interesting and would allow me
to contribute to your understanding at
least of my experience and what I think
is important one was the career that I
wanted to establish which was a career
that I'd hoped would be in the
investment banking business and which
allowed me to in fact develop my
activities in that field in in countries
other than my native Australia and to
finish out doing work in the middle of
the American investment banking
community and then starting my own firm
before I went off to the World Bank and
so I was able because of the
opportunities here to have first the
professional strand and then on the
other side to establish for myself ago
which was first to spend 20% of my time
and my income and then 30% and
ultimately more balancing life that I
was doing between business and
non-business activities and I have to
tell you just because as I look at this
room and think of my own background that
if there's one thing that I would as a
generality say to you it is that if it
is possible for you in whatever you're
doing to engage yourself in the thing
rather than the straight business course
you will find that not only does it
enrich your life but the truth of the
matter is that it'll enrich your
business because you engage yourself in
people and with people in the community
that have broader issues with which
they're engaged and they tend to be the
best people in the community the people
that have decided that it's not just a
singular interest in business which is
the thing that drives them but that
since business does survive within a
communal environment that that aspect of
duality in the life is something that I
found in my life it was the thing that
made it meaningful but it also gave me
the opportunity as a result of
activities in the field particularly not
just of the arts but of development in
which I became interested that it took
me into that area for which I suppose
I'm best known which was my period at
the World Bank and subsequently in the
Middle East but today I would like to
focus on the period in the World Bank
because it has some messages that I
think may be interesting to you and
certainly relevant and if I were your
age I would be thinking very seriously
about what it was that drove me to the
bank and what it was I learned there the
first thing I'd like to say is that
hacking back to my own experience I grew
up in a world in which for decades there
was one sixth of the world by the year
2000 a billion people who had 80% of the
world's income and then there were 5
billion people or in the so-called
developing world that had 20% of the
global income and I took an interest in
that 20% through activities in
foundations and I
of things largely because I couldn't
understand how the world would continue
in an inequitable distribution of five
billion having 20% in 1 billion having
80% of the world's GDP it still stood
there in the post-war years with varying
numbers of course in terms of the global
population but proportionately that was
the sort of relationship there's 80/20
which existed for decades but came the
last decade of the last century and
moving into this new century we're
seeing for the first time the swing
which now has that 8020 somewhere closer
to 70/30 or 72 28 or some such number
and that is an important and rapid
change which has occurred and it's
brought about a change which has been
very evident in the way in which
international institutions function that
in which in the the global economy
functions so much so that as we look out
the so-called 8020 that I and my
contemporaries grew up with it's now
looking at a very very different future
it is the future that you will face it
is a future of 9 billion people on the
planet by the year 2050 of the 3 billion
extra that have been added to the planet
or will be added to the planet from the
year 2000 about a hundred million goes
to the rich countries and 2.9 billion
goes to the developing countries so come
2050 it's not 1 billion and 5 billion
its 1.1 billion and 8 billion or close
to it that is a huge change dramatic
change
the other consequential change is that
the structure of the economy is being
driven both by the population
development and also by modern
technology which has allowed the
conveyance of ideas and innovation to
move to the developing world and so the
projections today are that that old
80/20 with which I grew up for decades
will become 35 65 35 2 cent for the
billion won in the rich countries and 65
percent for the people in the developing
countries that is turning the world on
its head in terms of the world that I
grew up in but it is the world that
you're going to work it and it is not a
trivial change it is a change of
monumental importance so much so that by
2050 China and India the two countries
that I have of course the leading
countries in the developing world will
constitute 50% of the global GDP 50% of
the global GDP that is the consensus
estimate but let's say we're off five
percent it's forty five percent of the
global GDP it's nonetheless a monumental
switch in terms of economic power it
happened last in 1815 when China and
India were 50 percent of the global GDP
and it happened before that in the year
1500 and in the period from 1815 at
various times it's been approaching that
but with communism and with the change
in governance in China and with the
greater development in terms of the
Industrial Revolution in the West you
got to a point where after World War 2
China and India were together 2% of the
global GDP so the growth in terms of
China and India and of Asia generally
is such that it is not just some
modulation of former trends it is an
absolutely fundamental change in the way
the world is balanced I remember I was
at a at a meeting of the g g7 g8 the
first time that the people from the
developing world leaders were invited
seven or eight leaders were invited by
Jacques Chirac to a meeting that was
held in France you'd be familiar with
the fact that the g7 g8 meet once a year
in June or July and generally until
recently decided what they think is
going to happen with the world and then
they might tell a few people outside
well it changed at that meeting and I
remember that the first person to speak
was who Jintao from China who made a
very elegant speech about China and
about the growth and about
interdependence between China and the
rest of the world
Prime Minister budge fire from India
then spoke I think probably eloquently
but I couldn't understand his English
very well so so I can only assume that
it was another brilliant speech but then
President Lula from Brazil got up and
said rather charmingly if only my
parents could see me now I came from a
very poor family and to see myself here
with you President Chirac and with you
the Prime Minister of England and you
the head of Germany and you detail the
people that were in the room he didn't
mention the president the World Bank but
he did mention the other minor people
that were there
and then he said then he said but I'd
like you to consider something and maybe
next year you should have your meeting
in Brazil and the reason you should do
that is because you should start getting
used to the fact that in another 10 or
12 years five of you are not going to be
here and we will be replaced by my
friend from China and my friend from
India and by myself and and and we'd
like you to get used to it so that you
can come see us well it was sort of
prescient because as you know when the
economic crisis hit very quickly it
moved from a g8 issue to a g20 issue and
now the g8 is part of the past and the
g20 is the new institution that is there
and it again fits into the prospective
development which I spoke which is that
the weighting of the planet is now
moving in different directions until
recently until we had this crisis the
United States had a sort of 10 trillion
consumption European Union had nine and
Asia and the rest of the developing
world had a little less than five
trillion dollars so it was ten nine five
and the middle class in in the world of
whom there today or a couple years ago
was a billion and a half roughly in the
middle class a billion was in the rich
countries in that in that group that I
spoke of and about half a billion in the
middle class characterized as incomes of
between ten and a hundred ten dollars
and a hundred dollars per capita per
week that this this amount of money was
demonstrated to be heavily leveraged to
the
richer countries by 2030 the estimate
now is that there will be 3 billion
people in the middle class and that 3
billion 2/3 of it will be in Asia 2/3 of
it so this is a switch from being a
fraction being less than 1/3 to being
2/3 and that is a pretty dramatic shift
you'll have a middle class in China of a
billion people billion people by 2050
middle class so these are not trivial
changes in the outlook
these are tectonic shifts in terms of
the way the planet works and as I said
to you as I look at all of you in my
generation we didn't have to think about
that in the Dean's generation it was
80/20 or 78 22 something like that it
was it was it was a balance where you
knew you were the rich countries the
powerful countries and all the organs of
running the world were designed to
accommodate that fact but the world that
you're going into is a very very
different one and it's not something
that is going to be turned back it's
something that will happen it may not
happen linearly there may be events that
will occur that will disrupt it for
three years or five years that may not
be exactly 6535 it may be a variation of
that but directionally it is very clear
and there are a couple of observations
that I think are interesting beyond that
but before I get to the observations let
me make one other point about the planet
and that is that there I say this in in
the presence of the Dean because in
Africa of the eight or nine hundred
million people that are now there that
will grow to two billion people by 2050
two billion out of nine billion and the
estimates are that the average
per-capita income for people in Africa
at that stage will be between two and
three thousand dollars per capita the
same projections would have China and
India are between thirty and forty
thousand dollars per capita so you've
got two to three thousand thirty to
forty thousand and countries in the
so-called rich world United States
European countries
somewhere between ninety and a hundred
thousand dollars per capita I'm not
giving you these figures with any sense
of mathematical accuracy they may be off
a bit but directionally they're right so
if you have two billion people living in
a continent with two to three thousand
dollars per capita you have China and
India with more people three to four
billion three billion between thirty and
forty thousand dollars per capita and
you have the rest of the world somewhere
either north of that or in a
middle-class somewhere between the two
countries the two areas of the world you
have a basis for instability Africa is
not a continent which is any longer
isolated it's not a place where people
are uninformed it's the fastest growing
market for cellular phones information
as you as you would well know and
whether it's in the townships or
wherever it is is now passes very
quickly and that's not just in South
Africa that's in the 53 countries in
sub-saharan Africa and this is not an
issue which is going to go away nor is
it an issue which is trivial to those of
us that live as we do here this is a
major issue which is not being
confronted and which you will have
to confront that substage and that gets
into a second issue which I would like
to touch on which is what is happening
with the rest of the world as it looks
at this changing dynamic having worked
in the World Bank and had some
familiarity with the whole issue of aid
I know just how tough it is to get
people in the rich world to really
understand what the responsibilities are
not just as a matter of conscience but
as a matter of enlightened self-interest
to try and help development in the
developing world there was established
decades ago a zero point 7 target for
foreign aid my colleague from the former
colleague from the SEC activity he was
here from a different part of Stanford
as I understand knows this and we're now
really after a lot of speeches and a lot
of activity we're starting to get some
momentum before the economic crisis of
15 months ago which we're now maybe
getting out of to a degree but it's now
not the zero-point-seven it's about zero
point two that we have reached and there
are a lot of statements that are still
being made but in terms of the actual
money which is flowing if you X out the
amount of money that are going to the
trouble spots in the world today there
is very very little development and in
fact the per capita contributions to
Africa have been declining steadily for
the last 10 or 15 years so one of the
tragedies is that there's great analysis
of the issues there's great
understanding of the issues but these
like the environment are long-term
issues and political decision making is
essentially short term
and so you have political decisions
which are being taken in terms of this
demonstrable development in terms of
global balance that certainly so far as
Western countries are concerned is not
being met what is interesting is to see
how the dynamic between Africa and China
and Africa and India is developing three
years ago for the first time the summit
meetings of the African leaders was held
in Beijing and they swore after that
that it was unlikely that they would
ever meet again in a western country
simultaneously 400 African businessmen
met in New Delhi and each led to a
understanding and the part about the
Chinese and the Indians of having a
dimension of their activities geared
towards Africa of course there's been an
Indian community in Africa particularly
in East Africa for a long time and
they're now 750,000 Chinese in Africa
and if you're in the business that I
mean I was recently in a African country
where we were involved in a in a real
estate development we went up country to
visit this real estate development and
which was near a university and I was
astonished to find that everybody on the
team that was doing the development was
Chinese the architects the town planners
the builders everyone was Chinese so if
you go to Africa today you don't see
people who come from Western business
schools you see people from China and
from India and I just raised that as a
point and the second point I would make
is that in terms of China and India in
terms of their development I was trying
to get the most recent numbers and they
may be in my my blackberry but I haven't
looked but the numbers in
2007 were the following there were a
hundred and ten thousand Chinese
studying in the United States there are
now over over a hundred thousand Indian
study in the United States so I look
around the room at suppose it's not
surprising there were eleven thousand
two hundred Americans studying in China
and two thousand eight hundred studying
in India this is madness
it's just madness and it's a tragedy in
terms of the potential for our young
people that are still being guided to
look towards Europe to look towards
graduate work in British or European
universities when the world is telling
them that the dimensions have changed
notably I was very interested to hear
that there's been a recent trip made by
some of your students to Asia and
another one to the Middle East but what
is needed in today's world is for us to
come up with what is the last thing that
I'll touch on which is this historically
the Western countries were able to stay
ahead firstly because of manufacturing
well that got taken out and
manufacturing moved to Asia the second
thing that happened after that was that
in service industries it moved to the
Western countries and now that's been
taken out in terms of Asian really
dominance in the service areas and
thirdly was in technology we were able
to stay ahead but this is evident to you
and I'm sure from your colleagues and
people you know the technological
advance is now shifted as well so the
challenge for our country is
what the hell is it that's going to be
left for us invasions eating our lunch
and dinner in terms of the things that
we used to be able to do and it's not
just the United States it is truly that
group of the so-called billion-plus
that were previously the dominant factor
who had 80% of the world's GDP
and so I leave you with that issue
because as as people that are going out
into the world if it were me today the
number one thing that I would be
thinking about which is different from
when I grew up is that the 80/20 rule
which I had comfortably in my hip pocket
is going to be a 3565 rule and that puts
a challenge of dramatic proportions to
anybody who's at a business school today
or graduating and so I was told that I
should go for about this time and I
would then be peppered with questions
that would be so intelligent that I
wouldn't be able to answer them so so so
so if there are questions I'd be
delighted to have a shot at them yes
ma'am about any soft I think that the
methodology of aid is the thing that
should be looked at I think that Africa
first of all is not a homogeneous place
with 53 countries there are some that I
think taking to themselves
responsibility for management governance
and there are some that are just very
sadly a long way away from it that a
essentially corrupt impossible places to
have management and so I think what you
need to do is to be selective the first
thing that I have become very impressed
by is that there are now a growing
number of young Africans or look around
the room I don't see too many here
a growing number of young Africans who
are going overseas for education and
these are black Africans these are not
just white South Africans or white other
Africans and they're coming back and
they are trying to find room for
themselves both in business and in
government and even in my decade at the
bank I saw a significant move in the
development of this core of young
Africans and then the question is to
what extent can they be backed by the
government's and to what extent is there
a framework in which there's a judicial
system in which there is governance in
which there is an attempt to counteract
corruption and to create some sort of
meritocracy and that is happening in
some countries in Africa I would say you
can see movement in 15 or 20 of the
countries of the 50 to 53 and I think it
is a trans African move now the thing
that I failed at doing was trying to get
the African leaders who were the most
enlightened to try and we tried to split
the continent into quartiles and have
the best of leadership deal with the
countries in each of these sectors led
by Africans enlightened African leaders
but unfortunately we failed because the
presidential system in these countries
and the leadership in all the countries
just made it impossible for us at that
time to try and encourage the
development of the best practices to
come to the top but I'm not totally
pessimistic because there is a change
but it's not nearly as quick as I would
like to see it and I think that aids
going to countries to answer
specifically your question aid going to
countries that will be corrupt and that
will wasted
is I hope going to become a thing of the
past you'll find humanitarian relief
going into those countries but it will
not be run by the government and there
needs to be a system of carrots and
sticks to try and get the countries to
change their practice so that the best
countries can be rewarded that by the
way was something that was brought in in
the Bush administration the rest
countries to be rewarded and say to the
others it's just not acceptable to steal
the money that we're giving it's going
to be a tough road but I believe we've
started on it
and I believe that the best advocates
are the enlightened African leaders
themselves not Westerners I believe that
that is now happening yes sir
considering this huge amount of change
especially away from the u.s. that you
talked about discuss how you think the
World Bank needs to change and also
concerning the u.s. president's ability
to appoint a leader of the World Bank
does that hinder I think that the the
old practice is I'm sure everyone knows
here was that the Europeans appointed
the head of the International Monetary
Fund and characteristically the United
States appointed the president of the
World Bank I think that is now a thing
of the past I think that has changed and
that it will be an open competition next
time part of the reason for this is that
the appointment of the person the
president of the World Bank was at a
time when the US economy was dominant
today that's no longer the case as I
said to you it used to be ten nine five
or ten percent tension in nineteen in
five trillion for the rest of the world
that is changing and as it changes I
have personally witnessed in my own time
at the bank a definitive change in the
way in which
groups of countries come together to
challenge American dominance first it
was the Europeans and then it's the BRIC
countries but it's very very clear and
so my own judgment is that the next
president of the World Bank is could be
American if there's someone dramatic but
it will not be as a right it will be
because that person is notably the best
person that you could have but I think
that in both institutions there now
internationalized and it is much more
likely that you'll have the best in
class for both the bank and the fund yes
China in India in the development of
Africa their business connections and
political connections and the welding is
openly criticized for not tying a to
environmental goals to love tying a to
human rights goals and the world has
been trying to move in that direction at
the same time now you have a second
player a second source of aid or some
form of capital then you know it doesn't
really impose that condition allottee as
of yet and I was just wondering how he
you know what do you think of the last
second and what does that mean for the
next 20 years well I think the first
thing is to challenge the first
assumption which is inherent in what
you're saying which is that Aid was tied
in to environmental or human rights
conditionality and I think personally
that that was more nominal than it was
real it was increasingly expressed in
the last 10 years but the truth of the
matter is that I don't think that there
was the hammer to come in to insist
there were all sorts of methodologies
that we use to produce arguments as to
why you are environmentally moving
forward or
were being more innovative in terms of
opening up the society to people I think
that it's not something that will change
instantly in history nothing by the way
has changed interest since instantly not
in terms of Europe and not in terms of
anywhere but I think that what we are on
is on a clear path which I am sad to say
has been arrested at least in terms of
the environment by the recent economic
downturn Copenhagen was a colossal
disappointment in my judgment certainly
relative to what many of us had hoped
for and the truth of the matter is that
leaders in countries the rich countries
in terms of the allocation of their
resources focus appropriately on what
are their domestic needs and because of
a downturn and the global economy for
the first time in 60 years last year it
has exacerbated the issue about what the
hell do we do in terms of getting our
own economies going when that happens
people in Africa or people in less
developed countries become secondary and
so what you tend to get aluminous
statements but not a lot of action and
that's why I said to you before in terms
of Africa the contributions over the
last 20 years per capita have been
declining not trivially but
significantly 50 percent decline and so
I think that we need to think we need a
turnaround in the economy and then
hopefully we need some global leadership
that is thinking beyond a four-year term
of political office
I haven't seen that in my lifetime yet
one of the great advocates by the way in
my years at the bank was Gordon Brown as
Chancellor and even as Prime Minister
but Gordon now has a problem with the UK
and so if he comes out and starts
talking about how much money he's going
to give to to the developing world it's
not going to help him in the next
election if anything would help have to
the next election
I hope something will but so I'm afraid
that we have caught up in this terrible
pattern of short-termism against
something which is an inevitable long
term problem and nowhere is that
long-term problem more evident or likely
to hit us than in the environmental
issue environment is something that you
know we're not going to be able to
decide in four years we're going to fix
it'll be more difficult to fix if we
leave at 12 years you can't fix it this
is not this is not this is a problem all
you guys are going to have to deal with
I'll be six feet under or something
that's good yes ma'am focus attention
investment levers what was it I would be
very supportive of non-governmental
intervention I think that the role of
civil society is crucial and I think
that the role in terms of funding
particularly for a small business
microcredit is an initiative that has
found its time I would go back however
to a crucial need of Education which I
think I heard my wife whispering on the
right
and if I didn't and if I didn't hear her
she would have given me a hell of a time
going back to New York this afternoon
but but education is clearly critical
clearly critical and that's boys
education but more crucially girls
education and those two things I think
are fundamental to what could happen in
Africa so you have a lot of changes
occurring in Africa you have the China
India thing which I spoke you have a
gradual move towards better more
responsible government and you have
civil society moving in broader ways and
it has previously part of the problem
however is that there are just too many
institutions in civil society that keep
falling all over each other and the
overheads are just killing I would
estimate that for every hundred dollars
that gets put aside for development
you'd be lucky of 30 to 35 cents gets to
the project in every dollar and the rest
is taken up by overhead stealing and
mismanagement and that is a that is a
hugely important issue which I've been
trying to deal a little bit since I left
the bay to try and see how you could get
a greater rationalization of the aid
business and just have a free pick up a
free pickup of 20% of whatever it is
that you're spending but again that's a
problem for all of you to face it's a
nice easy one I leave you yes sir
Chinese are investing heavily in the
natural resources
Africa do you see that as a opportunity
for stability in the region or will that
just allow the corrupt governments more
opportunity to maintain power well I
think those is the answer it is an
opportunity for improvement but in some
of the countries it's pretty evident the
the benefits are going sadly to a small
group and that's just a fact I wish it
were otherwise and it's not very clear
that the Chinese are at this stage
insisting on social benefits as a result
of the involvement in the countries
they're more interested in getting the
minerals out than in participating in
high-level debates about what is the
purpose of economic development up to
now that has been the position of the
Chinese I know a number of people in
Chinese leadership who would wish it to
be otherwise and would like to bring
about some change but the way the
Chinese system works even though I've
been there many many times is still
opaque to me and I think it needs a
decision at the top beyond just making
some speeches about it it needs to be
pushed down there I see a big
representation of Chinese in the room
maybe they can help you after this this
gathering and tell you the realities but
the big reality in China is to get
control of natural resources and even
with its aid programs in Africa
important as they are they tend to be
more attention getters in my judgment
than they are substantive it's not
wholly true but everywhere the the
president's house the town hall the
sports stadium is done by the Chinese
it's a very good thing to do but what is
really needed underneath that is to try
and change the societal structure
and I don't think up to now the Chinese
have attempted to do that and from my
little experience that I told you in
terms of this real estate development I
was doing in Ghana it doesn't help to
have 25 Chinese doing the development
and no gun ants if you're talking about
bringing along the economy yes the only
thing that they could do would be to get
in there and compete but they're not
going to influence China to change its
ways and they're not going to influence
African government to change their ways
because the interest is economic
development
maybe the Dean would have a different
view but I don't think that's the case I
think I think reality is that at the
moment the money is in the hands of the
economic growth powers that are looking
at natural resources particularly in
Africa the the interest is fundamentally
natural resources and in the case of
some Indian companies also retailing
where there is a big history of
manufacturing and selling in Africa but
it is a if we're going to compete first
of all we have to create a group of
leaders who give a damn about Africa and
then create a group of managers that are
prepared to live and work in Africa and
who care about Africa and who see it as
an economic possibility which it clearly
is but it's a little less transparent
than some other economic activities and
in the case of China and India they're
already in there throwing people at it
the growth in the China resident
population has just been enormous in the
last 10 years
three final questions sure yes ma'am
you mentioned that there's going to be a
tremendous shift in power wealth in the
future that is wondering if you had any
thoughts on are there some tenants or
guideposts from the past that you think
will help us move forward in the future
and chart our way through these unknown
waters this is what I was saying before
in my generation for a good 40 years of
my business activity there was no
challenge to the 80/20 it was in fact a
little higher at the end of the World
War two but basically 80/20 was the was
the profound understanding that people
had
I can only put the problem in front of
you which is that if 80/20 becomes 3565
and you've added another three billion
people to the planet that's a very
different world and frankly what worries
me is that people are not learning about
the history and culture of Asia they're
not learning the languages of Asia and
at least to the limited extent that I
know it certainly by the statistics
younger graduates are not prepared to
put themselves in Africa in Asia and so
I just hope that our educational system
will do something about training our
kids younger at primary school and in
both language and in culture and in
history and then have them go through so
that it universities they're already
interested in it
I have an image of three years ago I
gave a speech or two years ago gave a
speech at data University Peking
University
700 kids in the audience spoken English
no translation no translation and the
most fantastic questions that you could
possibly have there is no place in the
West where you could have 700 people in
an audience
speaking Mandarin oil or Cantonese and
have a Chinese speaker make such a
speech I'm not suggesting that we all
that the only yardstick is going out and
learning the language but I am
suggesting that in terms of culture and
in terms of direction we are miles
behind where we should be if we're going
to be competitive maybe different on the
west coast but certainly on the East
Coast a second one the end money how do
you see that shifting the military
balance and what sort of consequences of
my tone well I think you're ready to get
as you are now in our country a lot of a
lot of pressure for Less intervention
both financially and in human terms but
I must say that in the last year I can't
point to any great advances so I don't
know the answer to that question I would
just think intellectually that it has to
be true that if the economic weight is
shifting shifting with that will be
responsibility and part of that
responsibility will be military and
intervention in the issue of peace and
that's a whole other subject about the
balance between the United States Russia
and China which would require another
hour to get into and even then I'm not
sure I could give you an answer but I
can say that historically economic power
is nearly always led to
Nitori might and so if there is a huge
shift in in economic power
chances are you will see a significant
shift in military power as well there
was one other question yes what would be
your advice with regards to how about
the decision to get involved the Gummer
government side the most lateral side
nonprofit side and private sector I
think you can have a good career and a
good contribution and any one of those
four I don't think that it's essential
that if you're interested in economic
development that you need to be out of
business I think that you can be in
business and still have an influence I
think you can have an influence in the
UN I think and have an influence in the
World Bank I think you can have an
influence in other international
agencies I think the important thing if
I were to give advice to my own kids if
they were of an age is that I would try
very hard to have them go take a look
and spend a year and at least learn
something about Asia if my kids had come
to me and said they wanted to go study
at Oxford or in the Sorbonne I would be
vigorous in suggesting to them that they
go to China or India vigorous and so I
think that your generation although this
is a slightly older group than an
undergraduate group but there's still an
opportunity to understand that the world
that you're going to live in is a very
different world and I grew up here and I
don't think they have been an adequate
series of changes made in our
educational system or in the aspirations
of young people
to recognize that it's a very different
world when you're talking about 65% of
global GDP being outside the OECD
countries and there's a very different
world when China and India together have
50% of the global GDP and when
two-thirds of the middle-class are in
those countries and alone a billion in
China that's a different world and I
fear that our educational system
although I know nothing about the
Stanford system so I'm not making any
comment but I do know something about
some other places I fear that our
educational system is not caught up to
the realities and what is fascinating to
me is how the realities of the
composition of students and graduate
students and our universities is
reflecting the change that I've
described which is that there are many
more Chinese Indians Asians study to the
benefit of the entire community the same
is not true in Reverse
and I think it's a damn shame and
hopefully there will be a growing tide
of people that can understand that
learning about Chinese culture and
Indian culture and Asian culture is not
going backwards it is discovering
something which is enormous ly rich
profound and important and has to be
part of the balance of people's lives
thanks very much